[Musique]
le power 4
en découvrant le prototype du nouveau
par quatre en 1936 ils étaient peu
nombreux ce qui pouvait se douter être
en phase de larmes qui une fois
modernisée pour répondre aux exigences
de la guerre allait devenir un cheval de
bataille de l'armée allemande tout au
long du conflit comme il avait été
envisagé dès le départ le rôle du prince
zarcate était celui d'un char de soutien
ils devaient prêter main forte aux
vendeurs croient plus petit plus léger
qui allait quant à lui constitué l'épiné
dorsale des nouvelles panzer division de
former à la fin des années 30
la suite des événements les prouver que
la wehrmacht en concevant le panzer 4
avec une caisse et une tourelle plus
grande avaient d'une manière fortuite
créer une machine dont le potentiel est
passé celui des panzers 3 en conséquence
de quoi ces derniers plus nombreux
allaient devenir obsolète en tant que
chars de combat dès la fin de l'année 42
et laisser leur place aux panthers 4 la
production de celui-ci fut initialement
réduite
et il participa fréquemment au défilé
militaire en allemagne mais seulement
200 exemplaires avaient été construits
lorsque hitler donne alors d'envahir la
pologne est les penseurs 4 et leurs
équipages connu le baptême du feu au
matin du 1er septembre 1939
bien que le penseur quatre se sont
montrés performants pologne il était
saoul blindés une faiblesse qu'il
partage avec tous les chars allemands
engagés lors de cette campagne
le blindage la terreur du penseur cats
étaient vulnérables aux canons antichars
beaufort l'écart enfle inhumaines
déployés par les polonais
leur canonnier vrai également été aidé
par la croix allemand bien visible
peinte en blanc et jaune sur les flancs
ainsi que d'autres marquage tactique qui
détenait sur le fond gris foncé des
chars et constituer ainsi d'excellents
repères de visée
la leçon sur rapidement comprise et
beaucoup d'équipages de chars allemands
les occulter avec de la boue par la
suite le modèle dès qu'ils entrent en
production en octobre 39 reçu un
blindage plus épais passant de 15 à 20
mm
à l'origine il avait été dans les
intentions d'hitler d'attaqué à l'ouest
dès novembre 1939 mais cette date fut
repoussé de même que beaucoup d'autres
dans les mois qui suivirent même si
l'hiver 39-40 fait extrêmement froid
l'armée allemande continue de se
préparer dans la campagne qui s'annonce
est
sur ces images tournées sur les terrains
de manoeuvre de l'est du pays n'est pas
or 4 s'entraîne avec l'infanterie dans
le rôle de véhicules d'appui servant de
places pro pour les troupes équipées de
canons antichars de 37 mm
lorsque le 19 mai 1940 les allemands
lancèrent leur offensive à l'ouest ils
alignaient environ 280 par cas ce que
représente un 9e des deux mille cinq
cent soixante quatorze chars engagé dans
la campagne
bien que la feb l'addition de 69 engin
depuis le mois de septembre 1939 pouvait
encore le faible niveau de production de
ces machines elle restait suffisamment
nombreuses pour que chaque unité de
chars engagé dans la campagne puisse
déployer une compagnie de chars moyens
alignant de sissach aux engins
la vitesse à laquelle les français se
déclarèrent vaincu résultat plus de
l'emploi stratégique et tactique des
blindés allemands opérant en masse et de
concert avec la luftwaffe afin de
paralyser paniqué l'ennemi sous leur
puissance de feu que de la supériorité
des chars allemands
durant les opérations le panzer quatre
fils épreuve dans son rôle d'appui mais
lors des combats de chars il surmontera
limité notamment par son canon de 75 mm
incapables de pénétrer les blindages
lourds des chars b à b- français ou
mettez à deux britanniques
alors même que les unités blindées
allemandes réviser leurs engins au
lendemain de la reddition française les
yeux tournés vers la compagnie aérienne
de la luftwaffe contre la grande
bretagne hitler avait décidé d'attaquer
l'union soviétique en 1941
il leur donne un de planifier une
nouvelle campagne fondée sur le principe
que la méthode utilisée pour vaincre la
france pourrait être employé avec le
même succès sur le front de l'est
bien que cette campagne devait se faire
à plus grande échelle aucune mesure
prévisionnelle de suprise pour accélérer
la production d'armes et notamment celle
des chars
le beach ligue était le moyen idéal pour
hitler qui voulait mener des guerres à
bas coûts sans bousculer l'économie
allemande la production du panzer 4
reflète c'était un esprit puisque seuls
3 132 exemplaires produits entre juillet
40 mg et 41 dont 223 du modèle e sur
blindés et modernisé
lorsque le 22 juin 1941 hitler lança la
wehrmacht contre l'union soviétique les
forces engagées représenter la plus
grande invasion t elle a jamais tenté au
cours de l'histoire
le fer de lance de la machine de guerre
allemande dans l'est était son arme
blindés la panzer va se charger par
éclairs de détruire l'armée rouge par
une guerre éclair en russie occidentale
avant qu'elle ne puisse se replier à
l'intérieur du pays
sur le papier le nom de panzer division
belge est suggéré une expansion majeure
de l'armée blindée d'un total de dix
divisions débit la campagne de france la
wehrmacht aligner maintenant plus de
vingt-et-une division blindée dont 17
étaient engagés sur ce nouveau théâtre
d'opérations mais comme nous l'avons
déjà vu cette expansion apparente
n'était pas le résultat de
l'augmentation de la production de chats
mais celle d'une décision d'hitler en
septembre 40 de créer de nouvelles
unités réduisant les effectifs des
divisions déjà existantes
celle-ci se voyait constitué d'un seul
régiment shard une infanterie augmenté
en compensation cet expédient aller
contre l'acception selon laquelle à la
fin des années 30 pour être pleinement
efficace les pensions des visions
nécessité au moins 400 chars en 1940 la
plus puissante cancer division aligner
300 chars la décision d'hitler réduisit
la puissance moyenne dépenses r&d
visionna 160 chat qui perdure une grande
partie de leur efficacité
seulement ainsi les graines de l'échec
de larmes blindé au cours de la guerre
mondiale à venir
de telles considérations ne coulait pas
de source mais trois mois après le début
de l'opération barbarossa les divisions
blindées allemandes se comportèrent
comme prévu 3 descend rapidement à la
profondeur du territoire soviétique elle
surtout un grand nombre de prisonniers
et détruisirent ou capturèrent des
quantités colossales d'équipements
militaires dans de grandes batailles
d'encerclement sur un total de 3000 3
122 ch à hitler avait engagé seulement
438 par cas dans l'invasion d'un russie
bien que le nombre de chars produit
depuis la fin de la campagne de france
lui dérisoires il permit néanmoins
chaque compagnie de chars moyens
d'aligner une dizaine de chars d'appui
les équipages de chars et leurs
officiers ne mirent pas longtemps à
s'apercevoir que le renseignement
concernant les unités blindés
soviétiques étaient largement
insuffisant
jour et nuit les russes lancées contre
les allemands un nombre incalculable de
chars dans une tentative désespérée pour
briser l'élan des pins heures qui
s'enfonce et toujours plus en profondeur
à l'intérieur de la russie
presbytérienne avait estimé à 10 mille
le nombre de chars soviétiques avant le
début de la campagne et croyait même que
ce chiffre était au dessus de la vérité
en réalité le nombre de chars dix
semaines dans l'armée rouge était plus
du double le gros de ces effectifs
étaient très obsolètes et à présent les
carcasses de thé 26 et 28 des 38 et les
chars de la série bt gens chez les
routes tranché et chant donnant une
nouvelle preuve de l'efficacité des
canons des penseurs pour pénétrer les
ménages très faible de ces machines
mêmes larmes à faible vitesse initiale
des chars allemands étaient capables de
percer facilement le blindage des chars
soviétiques
mais cela n'était pas le cas lorsque les
penseurs de va affronter les rares chars
la nouvelle génération d'armes et rouge
dont les officiers c'est par tous les
moyens de freiner la progression des
colonnes blindées allemandes
le renseignement allemands n'avaient
donné aucune information concernant
l'existence des caves et un carnet de
étaient 34
malgré son blindage incliné son canon de
76 mm l'efficacité du thé 34 et des deux
autres chars précités fut sérieusement
émoussé par la mauvaise utilisation de
ces armes
pourtant excellent déployés par l'armée
rouge
les allemands peuvent ainsi compenser
leur infériorité technique en usant de
leur expertise tactique largement
supérieur comme c'est pas hors cadre de
la 18ème penseurs qui réussira déférente
et 34 en tournant autour et en tirant
dans ces chenilles mettant ainsi son
équipage ensuite
dans la plupart des cas les t34 l'ecc
avait été détruit par les canons de 88
mm et par l'artillerie
mais ces expédients deux firmes à ce
qu'ils avancent que les russes avaient
prises et à laquelle les allemands de
l'est maintenant répondre
en août hitler interrompu la marche sont
moscou et ordonnant au second penseurs
groupe du groupement centre de goût des
riam de pousser au sud est de soutenir
le groupement sud
celui ci devait encerclé détruire la
concentration troupes soviétiques dans
et autour de kiev mais les penseurs des
visions de commencer déjà montré des
signes de faiblesse depuis début
septembre plus de la moitié des charges
engagées au début de barbarossa avaient
été détruits ou étaient hors d'usagé la
capacité de réparer des machines pour
les renvoyer au combat résulter d'une
mauvaise logistique au niveau des pièces
détachées ce problème et est aggravée
par leur fils hitler de commander de
nouvelles machines remplacement
préférant les garder pour les affecter
aux nouvelles pointes soeur division qui
a été créé en allemagne
le 8 juillet il accepte d'emblée 15 par
quatre sur le front russe
quoi qu'il en soit la jonction des
penseurs de kleist et de goût derrière
de 14 septembre c'est là à la fois la
fin de la poche de kiev et le sort de
cinq corps d'armée soviétique
si 165000 russe moururent où furent
capturés le flanc du groupe pensante
maintenant nettoyer hitler donna son feu
vert pour la reprise de la marche sur
moscou
alors même que l'opération sur kiev
était concluante plusieurs le nord les
troupes allemandes étaient proches de
leningrad après une marche à travers les
pays baltes les deux puncheurs cordes du
groupement nord était prêt à prendre la
ville à la fin de la première semaine de
septembre
cependant et rire avait décidé qu'il
n'allait pas l'investir mais la mettre
en état de siège
le dune septembre général reinhardt reçu
lors de retirer son pointeur corp pour
le redéployés ailleurs
la nouvelle consternante est un majeur
qui ne comprenait pas ces décisions
les promeneurs de reinhardt était en
route vers le sud pour le rassemblement
avant la prise de smolensk
ils devaient participer à l'opération
qui font la grande offensive qui visait
à prendre moscou et achever la campagne
de russie avant l'arrivée de l'hiver
l'artillerie allemande était en place
autour de leningrad afin d'exécuter un
tir de barrage
le siège avait duré de septembre 42 à
février 43 et causé la mort d'un million
et demi de soldats et civils russes
durant la première semaine de
l'opération qui font fin septembre les
forces allemandes firent plus de 660
mille prisonniers supplémentaires lors
des deux batailles de vias mahé briansk
ouvrant la voie vers moscou
rien ne semblait pouvoir barrer la route
aux allemands hormis peut être la
difficulté du terrain
on aurait au centre de la ligne de front
les allemands découvrir que d'épaisses
forêts allait ralentir la progression
des panthers le temps comment ça a
changé et à partir de la mi-octobre la
nuit dur est déjà 14 heures
au sud les soviétiques attaqué en masse
pour la première fois avec leur t34 et
portèrent du dur coup aux puncheurs
groupe leguide erian et à la quatrième
paire division'
ils recommencent à cinq jours plus tard
et les panzers 4 au chenil étroite
virent leur mouvement entravé par ce
terrain meuble hébreu qui fini par
stopper toutes les unités
pris dans la boue des allemands
attendent ya l'arrivée du froid de
l'hiver et les russes profitant de ce
répit se préparer à recevoir
l'as vence repris le 15 novembre par un
tank l'air est glacial
le haut commandement de vente boc lu ici
en compagnie de guderian espérait
toujours pouvoir prendre moscou le 1er
décembre von boch avait changé d'avis et
ne croyaient plus la victoire possible
les températures avaient chuté et ni les
hommes dans leur uniforme d'été ni les
machines et leurs véhicules de soutien
n'était préparé pour une campagne
d'hiver la résistance des soviétiques
commençait à se durcir notablement
malgré tout la vence continua
alors que les températures descendaient
les cas d'injures se multipliaient de
manière alarmante les charges les la
nuit lesquels n'ont ne pouvait plus
tirer les organes de visée était gelé il
devint clair que les troupes allemandes
atteignaient leurs limites
bien que ces équipages de chars
apparaissent joyeux devant les caméras
les conditions de vie des panzer
division se détériorait rapidement
malgré un ultime effort l'espoir de
s'emparer de moscou s'évanouit en
particulier lorsque le renseignement
annonça que les renforts pré positionnés
devant la ville étaient les troupes
sibérienne
le 3 décembre
les allemands avaient joué leur dernière
carte et les soviétiques pas certes à la
conférence
le 15 février 1941 les chars et autres
blindés de l'afrika korps sous le
commandement du général erwin rommel
nouvellement arrivés par des dans les
rues de tripoli avant de repartir dans
le désert bouter les britanniques hors
de la cyrénaïque la petite force
commandée par home elle était composée
de la cinquième division légère avec à
peine 150 chars dont 40 seulement
étaient des panzers 3 et 40 autres
dépanneurs
4,7 et des modèles d et e qui servait au
sein des 5e et 8e régiment de panzers de
thé spécialement d'un équipement
tropicale avec notamment un filtre à air
et un gros radiateur fixé au dessus du
bloc moteur est protégé par ahmad al la
guerre des raids et contre raids
allaient faire maintenant rage le long
des côtes d'afrique du nord jusqu en
octobre 42
c'était réellement une guerre de
véhicules basés sur la mobilité mail
apparente capacité d'euros mais elle a
toujours gardé initiative ne dépendent
pas du tout de la qualité de ses blindés
la différence essentielle
entre les forces britanniques et
allemandes résidait dans la supériorité
des méthodes tactique et dans
l'efficacité des canons anti chars ainsi
que dans la manière dont les allemands
utilisaient leurs moyens constamment
coopération interarmes
le meilleur exemple était est la façon
norml déployer ses canons antichars et
ses canons antiaériens de 88 mm de
concert avec ses chars
ce qui apparaissait souvent comme une
masse d organiser deux chars voiture
blindée pièces d'artillerie et semi
chenilles et tractant des canons étaient
en réalité une machine de guerre
remarquablement flexible qui menaient
des opérations typique de la guerre du
désert
l'entraînement combinée à l'expérience
permettait aux canons d'être rapidement
mises en batterie et de fournir un appui
aux assauts blindés à moins que les
panzers ne se replient pour laisser le
champ libre aux canons antichars de 50
mm ou à la flotte et à ses tubes de 88
mm pour engager blindée britannique en
approche avant de lancer leur propre
riposte lors de telles opérations le
bonheur 4 n'avait aucun avantage
intrinsèque il n'était qu'un élément
mobile au sein de l'ensemble pour rom l
île fric du nord sur le théâtre
d'opérations où la guerre près sa forme
la plus moderne on peut voir sur ces
images des unités motorisées dont
l'emploi dans le désert plat sans
obstacle offrait des possibilités
inouïes
ici les principes de la guerre motorisés
blindés tels qu'ils avaient été enseigné
avant 1939 pouvait être pleinement mise
en application et plus important encore
développer
bien que mal commandé et les blindés
britannique était observée avec soin par
les équipages des panzers
le lourd blindage du matilda pouvaient
être seulement pénétrer par le canon
antiaérien de 88 mètres et le fun time
bien que faiblement armés se révéla une
cible difficile et fuyante
les sherman creuse hadders et grant
causèrent tous ces difficultés mais
jusqu'à l'arrivée du tigre le char
allemand le plus puissant reste à le
panzer quatre spéciales
l'offensive allemande de l'été 1942 en
russie méridionale vie le déploiement
d'un grand nombre de penseurs 4f deux
armées du canon k/w cas de 75 mm doté
d'un tube blond de calibre 40 3 ce
dernier avait été commandée par et les
en novembre de l'année précédente pour
que le panzer 4 dispose un canon
suffisamment puissants pour détruire les
cafés et thés 34 soviétique
comparé au modèle d'origine à faible
vitesse initiale
le camion long du f2 affichait une
vitesse initiale de 740 mètres seconde
permettant à l'ogive de pénétrer 82 mm
d'un blindage offrant un angle 30 degrés
en mars 1942 croupe stop à la production
défenseurs 4 pour permettre
l'installation des outils nécessaires à
la production des nouveaux canons
au moment où l'offensive d'été fut lancé
seul 250 exemplaires avaient été
produits et même si quelques-uns furent
envoyés en afrique du nord la plupart
partir pour le front de l'est où il
complétait avec brio l'arsenal des
panzer division malgré tout les journaux
films et de l'époque continuèrent de
montrer le panzer 3 comme le char le
plus répandu même si contrairement aux
apparences le panzer cats étaient
maintenant l'engin ayant le plus grand
potentiel
alors que les panzers six années la
steppe à la fin de l'été 42 l'avant
salma se concentrer sur la progression
vers le caucase afin de prendre les
champs pétrolifères et foncé sur la
volga vers stalingrad
la résistance soviétique faible en
apparence avait conforté hitler dans ses
idées préconçues à propos d'une russie
exemple
contrairement à 141 staline avait appris
à ne pas se laisser encerclé par de
grandes colonnes de panzers alors que
ses troupes se retirait à mesure que les
forces de l'axé avançait il ordonna
qu'une fois stalingrad elle cesse de
céder du terrain la décision dit l'air
de ne pas s'en tenir à son plan initial
et de dérouter la 4e penseurs armée vers
le sud pour attaquer rostov lui coûta la
prise de la ville au milieu de l'été le
temps qu'il réalise son erreur et
renvoie des éléments de la quatrième
phase heurts armés vers tallinn grade
les soviétiques s'étaient retranchés et
il était prêt à se battre jusqu'au
dernier
4ème armée avec la 6ème armée de vendre
paulus se battait aux abords de la ville
depuis début août et avait toutes les
raisons de penser que celle ci tomberait
assez facilement
les éléments de la quatrième vendeur
armés notamment les penseurs 4 f-22 la
24e panzer division se battaient dans
les quartiers sud de la ville
alors que la résistance aux soviétiques
se durcissait notablement les allemands
furent obligés par la configuration du
terrain d'utiliser leur précieux blindés
pour soutenir l'infanterie en combat
urbain une forme d' affrontements dans
laquelle les soviétiques étaient passés
maîtres et pour laquelle les chars
étaient totalement inadapté
la lutte se poursuivre indéfiniment
pendant l'automne les prémices de
l'échec allemand à stalingrad se
profilant à l'horizon
lentement mais sûrement
depuis l'occupation la france avait été
choisi par les allemands pour leur peau
et leurs équipements ne re division au
retour de russie
ici l'on peut voir des panzers 4g
flambant neuf appartenant la première
division ss life stand art adolf hitler
dans son plan de destruction intégrale
du groupement sud de l'armée allemande
staline avait lancé une série d'autres
offensives dans l'afflux de
l'encerclement de 6ème armée
à la fin janvier stalingrad était déjà
loin sur les arrières de l'armée rouge
en marche et bien que fantomatique même
dans ses dernières heures l'un 6ème
armée de vente par lot se mobiliser
encore l'attention d'état-major
soviétique et retenaient des troupes qui
sinon auraient été déployée avec celle
qui se chargeait de repousser les
allemands toujours plus à l'ouest en
février la position des allemands
semblaient perdus alors que les
soviétiques le repousser delà de la
ligne qu'ils occupaient avant le
lancement de l'offensive de 42
lorsque kharkov et abandonnés en dépit
de ses ordres directs et alors que la
retraite allemand se poursuivent et
hitler s'envola pour le quartier général
de von manstein corps et âme et sa tête
les soviétiques et en seulement quelques
kilomètres ils seront dix cependant
arguments de von manstein et lui donne
carte blanche pour mener une contre
offensive contre les troupes russes qui
s'étendit met en valeur le au sud-ouest
du fro le fer de lance de sa force était
le ss panzer corps qui comprenait la
première espionne prenant des divisions
match en date le site mais la seconde et
ses sponsors division das reich et la
troisième essai ce penseur division top
50 les trois division blindée ss était
revenu en russie après cette remise en
condition en france en apprenant le
redéploiement des troupes allemandes de
leurs blindés les soviétiques trop sûrs
d'eux interprétèrent comme la preuve
d'un retrait
au matin du 19 février vendent manstein
lança le s & spencer corde pour la
première phase de sa contre-offensive
prenant ainsi les russes totalement
déposé
[Musique]
sur ces images le plus remarquable
réside dans le changement des matériels
utilisés au sein des bataillons de chars
des division blindée ss qui préférait le
panzer 4 15h03 les derniers panzer toi
furent construits en février 43 ce qui
marqua la transition vers le power 4
comme chars de combat à l'armée de terre
allemande et des vins faits né cessent
les soviétiques mire du temps mesuré
l'importance de la contre offensive
allemande
entre les 4 et 6 mars et troupes
allemandes se regroupèrent puis
entamèrent la seconde phase de leur
assaut vers kharkov
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après un rapide redoute qui menaça de
stopper l'offensive
le retour des basses températures permis
la progression de se poursuivre les
canons de 81e de la saq divisionnaire
était maintenant tournés vers les
colonnes soviétique qui se repliaient
sur qu'archos
[Musique]
dans l'après-midi mars les ss c'est leur
entrée dans la banlieue de la ville de
violents combats eurent lieu lors des
jours qui suivirent les soviétiques
toujours à leur avantage sur ce type de
terrain défendirent chaque maison chaque
rue faisant payer un lourd tribut à la
cei en allemand
[Applaudissements]
on peut noter les chenilles spécial
utilisé par ces penseurs 4g l'une des
faiblesses du penseur 4 sur la neige
reste sa tendance à s'embourber à cause
de la forte pression au sol
les extensions longtemps la largeur des
chenilles sur l'un des moyens utilisés
pour régler ce problème c'est extension
baptisée austreten remplir le rôle bien
que sujette à de nombreuses pannes
[Applaudissements]
bon
il salue cinq jours de combats acharnés
aux troupes ss pour finalement conquérir
la ville les derniers soldats russes
restent en cacher dans l'usiné de
tracteurs
une avancée plus au nord au dessus de
kharkov permis de prendre belle garros
mais avec l'arrivée du dégel toutes les
opérations ultérieures furent
interrompus face au général vous
après l'invasion d'afrique du nord par
les alliés en novembre 42
hitler avait ordonné le rapide
renforcement des troupes allemandes
présentes sur la tête de pont en tunisie
s'efforce qui avait été refusé un
rebelle alors qu'il se trouvait très
menacée à l'ouest vers la tunisie et qui
aurait pu faire basculer l'issue des
batailles précédente et est maintenant
lancée sur la tête de pont avec
notamment un grand nombre de chars de la
cinquième phase est rare mais
ces penseurs katché appartenant à la
10ème panzer division de fürth en plein
lors de l'offensive nommée opération
brise de printemps c'est le 14 février
43 contre les américains à sidi bouzid
[Musique]
la victoire allemand n'était que
provisoire la tête de pont tunisienne ne
pouvait pas tenir face à la supériorité
alliés aussi bien sûr meilleur que dans
les airs et en mai cette position
s'effondra
après sa nomination par hitler en
février 43 en tant qu'inspecteur général
de l'armée blindée avec pour consigne de
remodeler complètement les forces
blindées allemandes
le premier souci du général heinz
guderian fut de mettre un terme à l'idée
émise par certains officiers supérieurs
mal informés mais cependant incluant de
stopper toute production du panzer 4 au
profit du tigre et du panther une telle
décision s'il avait été suivie auraient
signé la perte de l'armée allemande
des 1040 rend le peseur 4 restait le
seul char tester encore produit en
allant y est le seul candidat par des
chars de combat de lapin veut
il demanda également ce que la
production du panzer quatre sont
augmentés en 44-45 afin d'assurer
l'expansion de l'armé blindée au sein de
la wehrmacht il fut d'aller dans ce sens
par albert menès du reich pour
l'armement la production d'armes de
guerre qui avait été spécialement chargé
par hitler en janvier quarante-trois
d'augmenter la production de chars fut
ce au détriment des autres branches de
l'industrie de l'armement j'espère aller
travailler depuis sa nomination l'année
précédente à mobiliser l'économie
allemande augmenter de manière
substantielle la production d'armements
de fréquentes réunions telles que celles
présentées ici furent un des moyens
qu'il utilisa pour communiquer ses
objectifs et ses priorités et sa tâche
ne fut pas rendue plus facile par la
nature byzantine du système nazi
quoi qu'il en soit les chiffres de
production du panzer cas peuvent donner
une bonne idée les progrès accomplis
alors que seuls 31 exemplaires avaient
été produits en janvier 41 un an plus
tard la production des petites arrivé
qu'à 58 exemplaires mensuels
mais en janvier quarante-trois les
cylons vos mac niveau l'oms et que les
mêmes que crew groupe initiateur du
programme poussèrent la production à 163
exemplaires par mois et en juin
précédent immédiat pour l'offensive de
elle avait grimpé à 1 272 chars
la cadence continue à augmenter un
tennis en pic maximal en février 45 ou
485 exemple et à khiter les chaînes de
montage
[Musique]
en avril 43 le premier penseur carte h
sortie de lusine se fit le modèle
produit en plus grand nombre avec un
total de trois mille sept cent soixante
quatorze exemplaires construits entre sa
sortie le moment il fut remplacé par le
modèle j en juin 44
bien qu'il fût sur blindés qui les subit
de nombreuses autres modifications
sa caractéristique la plus évidente et
essai shirts ou des jus blindés conçus
pour lui donner une protection
permanente contre le fusil anti chars
soviétiques et les bazookas des alliés
ses jupes latérales de 5 mm devaient
désormais modifier l'angle d'attaqué
projectiles pour réduire leur capacité
de pénétration
alors que les jupes équipant la torah
l'été fixe les choses se présentent sur
les flancs de l'engin terme bible bien
que la bataille de koursk certainement
moins connue celle de stalingrad elle
symbolise aux yeux du public le
déploiement de chars tigre allemand dans
la mythologie soviétique le titre les
tigres brûlé devenu un véritable symbole
d'un 17 allemande l'order dernier en
grande offensive sur le front de l'est
de prodigieuses efforts avaient été
faits par les allemands pour des pays
2700 chars et canon d'assaut lors de
leur dernière tentative pour détruire
l'armée rouge à koursk en juillet 43
près d'un cinquième de tous les blindés
disponible au 30 juin étaient présents y
compris des panzers cap des groupements
centre et sud
les 680 par 4 inclut un certain nombre
de pzk d'origine qui avaient survécu
mais le gros des troupes étaient dotées
de modèles f2 des premiers modèles j
avec le cas noël 43 et des derniers
modèles g a charmé duel 48
presque tous les penseurs 3 tout marion
2 confondues participé à l'offensive
ce qui n'empêcha pas course d'être le
chant du cygne du panzer trois ententes
chars de combat puisqu'il n'était plus
produit depuis juin 1943 que les fortes
pertes enregistrées par ce char
achevèrent de le rendre inutile en
revanche les nombreux penseurs quatre
engagés dans l'opération citadelle
marquèrent les maires gensse de celui ci
non plus en tant que véhicule d'appui
mais comme principal chars de combat des
panzer division
avec les taux de perte alarmant subis
notamment par les panhard 4 à koursk
goudé rien observa que les unités
blindées qui avait fait tant d'efforts
pour s'équiper avait malgré tout subi de
lourdes pertes aussi bien en hommes
qu'en matériel et restera indisponible
pendant une longue période
koursk reste considéré par les
soviétiques comme la bataille qui permis
de briser les reins à pantin veut sur le
front de l'est
conséquence de l'opération citadelle
n'est pas sa division très diminuée dû
recomposer avec une armée rouge qui
avait retrouvé des couleurs est passé
maintenant à l'offensive dans cette
séquence les panhard cas de la division
ss das reich entre en action pour
contrer l'offensive soviétique visant à
prendre la position des allemands sud de
kharkov
tandis que le succès la wehrmacht qui
fait profiter ici d'un répit temporaire
il ne reflète cependant pas le bilan
global est à partir de la fin d'été 43
les allemands battaient en retraite
dans de telles circonstances le travail
des équipes de maintenance des ateliers
de campagne revêt une plus grande
importance à ce stade de la guerre les
allemands disposer d'un système efficace
pour ramener du champ de bataille les
charges endommagé au combat sur ces
images on voit un semis chénier de 18
tonnes doté d'une grue de 6 tonnes
ceci permet de réaliser des réparations
complexe sans avoir à envoyer les
machines endommagées en allemagne
remontez la tourelle sur le châssis
nécessité de faire intentions dommages
subis par à l'anneau de celle-ci et au
mécanisme de rotation
ce plan rapproché de l'un des huit
galets de roulement sur le bas de caisse
permet de bien observer la suspension à
ressorts elliptique du panzer 4
le grand nombre de dégâts dus aux mines
faisait du remplacement de ses pièces
une opération courante au sein des
unités présentes en russie en afrique du
nord
la position externe du train de
roulement permettait un accès facile
lorsqu une réparation était nécessaire
avant le rivetage de la caisse et les
conduites de refroidissement du bloc
moteur est appliqué une couche de
peinture jaune sombre utilisé comme base
surtout les panzers à partir de février
le schéma présents ici assez confus le
char transporté affiche une livrée ou le
vert-olive le brun rouge ont été ajoutés
à la fin de l'été et au début de
l'automne 43 les panzers quatre furent
engagés dans de violents combats lors de
la retraite vers l'ouest au delà d'une y
apprend il est possible même à ce stade
de la guerre de distinguer milieu des
panthers 4-2 télé sur ceux de vieux
survivent encore armé du canon de 75 mm
cours est toujours utilisé comme chardin
puis
contrairement leur chef les pilotes de
panzers n'était que rarement mis en
avant mais en septembre 43 ans est à
l'heure où leurs chars fureur de la
deuxième ss panzer division das reich
fait chevalier de la croix de fer pour
son incroyable courage
après avoir détruit 3 t34 son engin fut
touchée bien que son chef de shao
ordonné à l'équipage d'évacuer le blindé
tu as l'air resta est sous le feu
réaliser une réparation de fortune sur
la direction et si repartir l'engin
dans la demi-heure qui suit son penseur
4g fils est victime parmi les blindés
russes pris par un cameraman à travers
la visée du pilote un panzer 4 a
soigneusement camouflés appartenant la
deuxième première division s'est
lentement mouvement pour engager un t34
que l'on verra rapidement en se
la step est un endroit chaud et aux
températures estivales ne sont pas les
meilleures conditions pour la visibilité
les optiques également d'une qualité
supérieure et plus sophistiquées que
celles de l'armée rouge donnant chef de
char allemand un avantage au premier tir
jusqu'à l'introduction du modèle 85 des
bus 44 le des 34 malgré ses qualités
avec une tourelle accueillant deux
hommes et le chef de chat était
également de charger
cette double tâche réduisent et son
efficacité au combat avec une tourelle
abritant trois hommes le parquet n'était
plus opérationnel et la charge de
travail pour chaque homme mieux répartie
quoi qu'il en soit à l'automne la
wehrmacht sur le front de l'est avait
cédé animant ce terrain l'armée rouge et
dans les mois qui suivirent la bataille
de koursk elle ne pouvait espérer aucun
répit en entendant outre l'hiver de
nouvelles offensives soviétique
juste après sa nomination au poste de
commandant en chef en grèce le maréchal
air ou une rom elle s'envola pour
salonique le 5 juillet 1943 afin d'y
inspecter ses défenses hitler avait
mordu à l'hameçon des alliés ceux ci
avaient réussi à lui faire croire qu'ils
allaient effectuer des débarquements et
hitler avait déployé la première
quinzaine des visions leurs renforts
dans le pays
l'intention des alliés était d'amener
hitler à disperser ses forces en dehors
de l'italie où le réel débarquement
devaient avoir lieu
les panzers 4 visible dans cette
séquence sont tous les modèles g de fins
de production et ils sont tous
recouverts d'une couche de jaune sombre
chacun est doté de silence pour
fumigènes présent standard sur ce modèle
il n'est pas surprenant que les
équipages apprécié d'aller à la mer
avec des températures extérieures
avoisinant les 30 degrés l'intérieur du
char devenait une véritable fournaise à
plus de 37 degrés pour les cinq membres
de l'équipage supposant que la reddition
du l'italie n'était qu'une question de
temps hitler les seins des consignes
pour l'occupation du pays après
l'annnonce du 8 septembre le mot de
passe axe fut transmis aux maréchaux
fromelles et kesselring qui déploie hier
des forces en italie du nord par la
passe de brenner et la voie ferroviaire
tandis que les journaux films et
suggéraient que la progression de
l'armée des ss en italie était largement
soutenu par les habitants l'arrivée
d'une telle masse de troupes allemandes
signifier que italie elle même donné ta
théâtre d'opérations alors que les
allemands voulaient repousser les
débarquement allié et leur avance dans
la péninsule
[Musique]
bien qu'ils pierre eu d'abord
l'intention de transférer tout le ss
panzer corse en italie après course la
situation très dégradée en russie permis
seulement de redéployer la ligue
standaard qui arrive à milan où la
présence de ces panzer 4 était plus que
nécessaire pour que les habitants
restent loyaux à la cause fasciste
l'italie n'était pas un pays où la
géographie et est très propice au combat
de chars par conséquent le nombre de
panzer division hommes déployés là-bas
n'allez variés que d'un à trois les
canons d'assaut les automoteurs était
bien plus utile et qui irait bien mieux
partie du terrain compartimentée de
l'italie c'est panzer 4h appartiennent à
la 15e par leurs divisions engagé sur la
péninsule
en russie les combats très violents
durèrent tout l'hiver les ressources
soviétique était telle que l'armée rouge
pouvaient maintenant poursuivre seul
enfant aussi dans n'importe quelles
conditions
ces powercat participe à un violent
affrontement avec le groupe nord à la
fin de l'hiver 43 44
ce fut la profonde neige de l'hiver
russe et la facilité avec laquelle les
chars allemands s'embourbait du fait de
leur étroite chenilles qui menèrent au
développement des os creten visible ici
sera panzer 4g en coopération avec un
détachement de canon d'assaut les
panzers 4 ouvre le feu à distance de
combat sur un élément de tête soviétique
un observateur indique ici une positions
d'artillerie depuis laquelle une
batterie de canons de 150 mm ouvrent le
feu sur les russes
les désastres militaires et les
mauvaises nouvelles du front de l'est
lors de l'hiver 43-44 font que peu
d'image ont été tournés pour la
propagande dès qu'une victoire est
acquise elle faisait la une
ce fut notamment le cas lorsque les
cameramans couvrir la somme lundi qui
permit de prendre cauvel en ukraine
septentrionale alors qu'un groupement
commandé par le ss gruppen fourrure
herbert jill y était encerclé par les
soviétiques à la mi-mars 44
bien capté détachement de panthère de la
division ss wiking réussit à percer pour
renforcer les défenses quelques jours
auparavant l'attak principal n'eut pas
lieu avant début avril
les éléments de la 4è penseurs division'
commandé par l'auberge hoffman et les
unités ss de la wiking firent une percée
à travers la ville en passant par la
route venant de brest litovsk parmi les
blindés soviétiques détruit ce trou de
l'ombre sherman m4a deux acquis via le
prêt bail qui apparaissent de plus en
plus souvent sur les images tournées par
les allemands depuis bien 144 lé
groupement blindé composé de chars et
l'auto motor issus d'unités mixtes
furent une solution fréquemment employé
pour répondre aux contingences du front
de l'est où le soviétique attaquer les
lignes de ravitaillement toujours plus
étirés des allemands de telles
opérations ne pouvaient être menée que
par des troupes mobile
ces actions ont permis de démontrer que
malgré l'écrasante supériorité
matérielle de l'armée rouge les
tankistes allemands restent maîtres dans
l'utilisation des penseurs et ce fut
vrai jusqu'à la chute de l'allemagne
plus rares alors qu'il ya pas tiger cats
overstrike n'attrape man
[Musique]
les troupes de l'armée hongroise le
joueur plus un rôle sur le front de
l'est à partir de début 44 leurs
activités restant cantonné aux arrières
bien que sous commandement allemand quoi
qu'il en soit la propagande de goebbels
continua de des peines leurs
collaborations comme étroite n'est
fondée sur le même engagement dans la
croisade anti bolchévique
lorsque l'occasion se présentait ils ont
filmé des exemples à destination des
publics allemands comme ici la garde
d'une unité de panzers 4 qui permit de
lauret de la croix de fer deux officiers
ont droit les panzers quatre sont les
derniers modèles h et porte le
dispositif contre les mines magnétiques
connu sous le nom de j mérite
[Musique]
comme pour répondre à l'attenté en
allemagne de l'inévitable l'invasion
alliée en europe au début de l'été 1944
le public allemand fut abreuver de
description détaillée des défenses du
mur de l'atlantique et des forces
regroupées en france dans le but de les
repousser
la plupart des défenses fixe abritant
les batteries d'artillerie lourde en
plus d'être un tiers nantes étaient
positionnées le long du pas de calais et
dans le secteur de la 15e armée qui
s'étendait de la belgique à la somme là
où les officiers supérieurs allemands
s'attendaient à un débarquement
une opération de désinformation menée de
main de maître par les alliés conforta
les allemands dans cette idée tout le
long des mois de juin et de juillet et
les poussent à croire que le
débarquement en normandie n'était qu'un
prélude au débarquement principaux qui
aurait alors lieu dans cette zone
au cours de son programme de
construction des défenses côtières
rommel alla jusqu'à ouvrir les digues
pour inonder les polders hollandais
larmes blindées allemandes étaient une
nouvelle fois la clé pour contrer les
débarquement allié
le 1er juin pas moins de 700 panzer 4
était d'y positionner en france
les unités de chars de même que
l'infanterie s'entraînaient avant que la
soient liés ne soit donnée mettant à
contribution leurs capacités de combat
et les ressources dont dispose et les
allemands a été partout disperser et
dans beaucoup de cas étaient positionnés
au mauvais moment
[Musique]
et cameraman étaient aux premières loges
pour filmer le maréchal gerd von
rundstedt lorsqu il inspecta à la 12è ss
panzer division it here you get
nouvellement créée et entraînée et
équipée avant le jour du débarquement en
plus de ses 48 panthères la hitler
jugend aligné pas moins de 91 panzer 4
et dans les jours qui suivirent l année
se tailler une solide réputation au sein
des waffen ss
la question du meilleur emploi des
poseurs division' face à l'invasion
prochaine causa de grands remous au sein
du haut commandement allemand
remède était partisan de laisser les
penseurs suffisamment en avant pour
pouvoir attaquer les années des coûts
devrait toucher terre
estimant que selon les expériences
précédentes
à moins qu'il ne soit stoppée dans les
24 heures les départements allier
réussir est
la réalité de la suprématie aérienne
alliée rendait caduque la stratégie de
guerre vol shepell bourgue commandant le
groupement blindé ouest qui voulait
laisser les alliés débarquent et pour
écraser leurs forces en aval de la tête
de pont le dilemme n'étaient toujours
pas résolues au moment où les forces
alliées se mirent en route
[Musique]
on
lorsque finalement le débarquement eu
lieu le 6 juin 1944
les forces allemandes surprise
totalement dépourvu
avec romane partie en permission en
allemagne tout espoir d'un déploiement
rapide dépend des indivisions pour
attaquer les plages du débarquement dans
les heures qui suivirent furent réduits
à néant
après la vaine contre attaque de l'a21
panzer division 2 6 juin ce ne fut le
lendemain seulement que la douzième ace
et ce par sa division arriva sur les
lieux et qu'une attaque déterminé fut
lancée par les allemands seul le
bataillon de candeur catarivas accord
dans la nuit du 6 au 7 le bataillon de
panthère ayant été retardé par
l'aviation alliée
malgré tout la décision fut prise
attaquer
et les ordres donnés par le général de
division fric vtt assez clair
le bataillon de panhard cas de les
frapper l'ennemi le long des lignes
ferroviaires entre quant à luc sur mer
et leur poussée vers la mer
alors qu'elle attaque était prévu pour
16h les allemands furent pris de court
par l'avant de la troisième division
canadienne vers caen où ces derniers
devaient prendre et tenir l'aérodrome
[Musique]
quatre par quatre en reconnaissant sur
intercepté par des chars man et trois
d'entre eux rapidement mis hors de
combat
pendant ce temps l'auberge tombe en
fureur max von schell ans a
immédiatement
[Musique]
les images montrées ici surprise au
cours du combat qui s'ensuivit écho
parmi les meilleures images du panzer 4
en action à la fin de la guerre des 54
des prix par itunes lors de cette
attaque la caméra ne faisait que
l'action des 5e 6e compagnie qui
flanquaient les canadiens
tandis que la sixième compagnie
détruisez plus de ti chars elles
perdaient également cinq de ces penseurs
quatre sous le sceau canadien
les penseurs de la sixième compagnie
poursuivirent leur progression à travers
le terrain mais surprise à partie par
une ligne de canons antichars de six
livres canadiens embusqués
59,4 surcouche est détruit à la fin de
journée le bilan était de 14 par zerka
perdu pour 27 chars canadien détruits
même si ces images sont accompagnées
d'une musique stridente est
triomphaliste signifiant que les jeunes
aient cette zone est de remporter une
grande victoire
en réalité la possibilité pour les
allemands détruire les positions alliés
s'étaient envolées
la taille de la hitlerjugend se
poursuivit jusqu'à la tombée de la nuit
le 7 juin fut seulement le premier genre
de combat de ce qui allait devenir deux
mois d'affrontements violents à la fin
desquels la division cesserait d'exister
le départ le 25 ou de la division montra
que seuls dix chars avaient survécu à la
campagne de normandie
les images de ponza requête en action
lors de la bataille de normandie sont
rares ce qui est surprenant pour le char
allemand le plus répandu
très peu de panzers survécurent à la
campagne de normandie
les pertes un porteur de pandore 4 sur
les fronts de l'est et de l'ouest à la
fin de l'année 44 aboutir une chute
massive de leur disponibilité au combat
on le constate notamment par leur petit
nombre lors de la bataille des ardennes
bien qu hitler a ordonné la préparation
soigneuse de l'armé blindée pour
l'opération brume d'automne seul 259
exemplaires et est disponible sur une
forte total de 2007 150 chars et canon
d'assaut engagés dans l'offensive
même si 1110 par quatre avaient été
construits entre octobre et décembre la
production des chars étaient descendus à
700 machines par mois à ce stade de la
guerre
le panzer 4 n'était pas seulement
l'engin le plus utilisé mais il était
également le plus vulnérable
ces deux facteurs constitue la plus
plausible explications du déclin relatif
de la disponibilité du panzer 4
à la fin d'été 44 l'armée rouge avait
virtuellement détruits le groupement
centre et atteint la frontière polonaise
c'est panzer 4 alignés le long de la
route font ici mouvement pour aller au
contact de l'ennemi
lorsque le combat est engagé les chars
soviétiques détruits par les canons des
panthers 4 sont le plus souvent des
chars manne issue du prêt bail
la des contrastes les plus remarquables
entre la guerre menée à l'est et celle
menée à l'ouest hérésie dans le rôle de
l'aviation bien moins important dans la
première que dans la seconde
les informations publiques allemandes
montrèrent le déplacement rapide par
voie ferroviaire d'unités de combat sur
le front de l'est passant d'un secteur
d'anjou un autre ce qui n'aurait pas été
possible sur le front de l'ouest
l'absence de couverts pour les panzers
faisait que la menace première des
unités blindées allemandes ne venait pas
de l'aviation soviétique mais du nombre
infini de shark les rues semblait
pouvoir déployer
cette séquence en plus orientale à la
fin 1944 montrent les derniers modèles
de panzers cats en action les
changements les plus évidents sur le
nouveau système d'échappement et
l'emploi de filet au lieu de shon
métallique standard
il est pas hors cadre ce martyr ainsi
contre l'armée rouge jusqu'à la
capitulation de l'allemagne en 1945 on
voit sur les dernières images tournées
par la propagande allemande un groupe de
combat comprenant au moins un par 4
l'histoire du panzer 4 au combat le seul
char étant restés en production sur
toute la durée la seconde guerre
mondiale ne se terminera pas pour autant
avec elle le dernier au but il pas un
panzer 4 le fut par un panzer cadre aux
couleurs syrienne contre les
installations de salles sur le plateau
du golan au camp des années 60
leur baroud d'honneur se situe en juin
67 lorsqu'israël pryda sur la montagne
et s'empara de ces chars certains y ont
été conservés en témoignage dix-sept
mille trois cent cinquante exemplaires
du pin up 4 construit toutes versions
confondues entre 1938 et 1945
[Musique]